tell Marisa let's mana he's asked once I
felt terribly guilty
I've been sitting around here in Berlin
while my home country is going through
the most politically relevant thing that
can happen in a society
why was it so sale poison I'm looking
forward to my trip I want to talk to
people I want to see what's happening
with my own eyes not filtered through
the media
it's always something ambivalent for me
to visit Ukraine I've gone there often
but just twice for political reasons it
feels like going home but it also feels
foreign I don't really know the country
anymore
meanwhile marina vice pundit knows
another country much better Germany her
second home the vice Pont family moved
here when marina was 7 they arrived as
part of a quota program for Jewish
refugees since receiving a dignity like
different things about Berlin and about
Germany what I like about Berlin is
exactly what I don't like about Germany
Berlin is cosmopolitan that might sound
like a cliche but in Berlin people don't
pay so much attention to rules you can
walk down the street at night and
suddenly there's a spontaneous jazz
concert right in the middle of the
bridge with people stopping to listen
and dance that's what I like about
Berlin life is relaxed here today Modena
vice bunt is a well-known face in German
politics as the former political
director of the pirate party she led the
party to its biggest victories in
Germany to date and now she's paying a
visit to her childhood home to a country
in the midst of one of the greatest
upheavals in its history
it's one week before the eruption of
violence in Kiev and the subsequent
outstare of President Viktor Yanukovych
but as she lands the dramatic events on
Independence Square the Maidan still lie
ahead for now there is still hope that
the protests will lead to a peaceful
solution marinus uncle Nikolai and aunt
Olga are waiting for her at the airport
today is a special day their niece has
finally returned a rare but welcome
guests from Germany Ukraine lies opens
my eyes to the ways in which I feel
Ukrainian and feel connected to Ukraine
how I speak how I party and enjoy myself
these are my roots
marinas extended family has gathered in
her cousin Vladimir's house at the edge
of Kiev the table is covered with all
their favorite traditional Russian and
Ukrainian dishes mazes me that whenever
I go back even if it's years later my
relatives still look the same they say
the same things and that sense of warmth
is there right away it's as if I'd never
left I never have to feel like a
foreigner or like I'm an intruder in the
family when I'm in Ukraine it's home
it's the food I've been used to ever
since I was a young girl it's that
feeling that all is right with the world
the family celebrates marinas arrival
long into the night
the next morning Kiev is quiet but
there's a palpable tension in the air
the protests are in their 13th week
later we'll realize that this was the
calm before the storm
Hestia angle condition under dante is my
first impression of the city came when I
went for a walk on the Maidan
it was intense I spent a lot of time in
Kiev and I've seen many protests here
but this was intense
what's this I didn't know what to expect
would it be a crowd with people
screaming at each other or an
emotionally charged situation or a
pseudo military camp or what it's
strange to suddenly see smoking steaming
barricades on the elegant fish took
Boulevard well you'll find Kia's most
expensive shops
it's like ordinary life is suddenly
superimposed with scenes out of a movie
suddenly the world of film is the real
world but it also makes me feel like yes
because this is justice the people who
shop here don't have much to do with the
other Ukraine the Ukraine where old
people collect used bottles for the
deposit where people can't afford tea
we're sick people can't afford treatment
it's a social divide that's almost
painful different parts of society
occupied the same physical space but
they have nothing to do with each other
and suddenly there's this cry this
protest against injustice
what's happening now is good because
Ukrainians are discovering that they
have the power not politicians instead
of just exchanging one politician for
another they're starting to say we are
the ones who count
it's our voices that need to be heard
many people here say God sees that we're
standing here in peace God will find a
solution but I can't yet see a way for
this to end peacefully and today's peace
won't last five days later blood will be
spilled here on Independence Square what
do we want to achieve we want to join
the European Union
and we want Ukraine to get rid of those
bandits up there who've robbed and
plundered the entire country not just
one or two of us but all of us it's not
just old people like me who've come here
and there aren't any politicians here
it's also young people and students the
future belongs to them they want Ukraine
to join the EU not because the EU has
cheap sausage and pricey cars but
because they want to live under the rule
of law I'm convinced God will help us
God is with us here but what about the
protesters who are willing to use
violence I've seen some of them
practicing attack maneuvers isn't that
true if we have to we'll defend
ourselves if the authorities want a
bloodbath we have to defend ourselves
but I'll say this human life is the most
important thing on both sides the way
okay
you must mention I don't want to just go
into details with one person I want to
talk to a lot of different people about
their opinions talking to people is easy
here on the Maidan it's almost automatic
there's a strong sense of solidarity the
woman I spoke to wanted to give me a
kiss because she felt we're on the same
side
fighting the same battle that's unusual
here in Ukraine that kind of openness
towards strangers the mood in Kiev City
Hall is a very different one various
opposition groups are still occupying
the building the far-right wing of the
anti-government opposition is dominant
here there's this faux bois de Partie
and its controversial hero stepan
bandera who led a nationalist movement
in the western ukraine for some is a
national hero for others a Nazi
collaborator and a criminal
the Nachtigal flag is a reference to a
Ukrainian Nazi battalion during the
Second World War
most of these flags belong to the
Svoboda party which means freedom the
party has a very definite program and
most of the demonstrators don't see that
as a problem they say of course they're
fighting for Ukraine's freedom it's our
country and nationalism is healthy
that's the way it is but even though
some of my friends agree with that I
don't share that opinion I think there's
a danger that they might not be seeing
because they don't share a history like
Germany's they might not have learned
all that much about history and about
how it all got started the roots of it
I've never experienced any anti-semitism
myself here and certainly not on the
Maidan and no one has told me about any
problems but I'm still hoping to talk to
people in the Jewish community about
what they've seen and experienced but
what I've heard is that family friends
people I know have said casually well
he's probably a Jew he's too clever to
stand in the first row so the idea of
the clever Jew that is something I've
come across
keya funded the Upper River was once
compared to Jerusalem because of its
Orthodox Christian monasteries and
churches
today some 2.8 million people live in
Ukraine's largest city
Niva Kiev I love Kiev Kiev is like a
familiar friend or lover that might
sound like a cliche but I feel close to
the city and that's not something I feel
so often
more than 20 years after the fall of the
Soviet Union and Ukraine's independence
Western Goods and Western fashion are a
common sight on Kiev streets but for
many these luxuries are out of reach
Ukraine is one of Europe's poorest
countries
you mentioned music OPI the people here
are more European in their dress
nowadays but they don't look more
European they have that look of grim
determination on their faces they know
their handbag might get stolen they
can't leave any cash at home because
that might get stolen too they can't buy
insurance because they think the
insurance will take their money but
never pay anything out that look of
tension and weariness is very typical of
Kiev I think garbage at first us in Kiev
cetera business
here ma Playland here and in Ukraine as
a whole don't have an easy life the
mentality goes back to the 1990s that
you have to take everything you can get
it's not that people are bad really or
different it was just a way to survive
woman I'm always amazed at how
Ukrainians managed to keep their sense
of humor even if they're just struggling
to keep their head above water so you
have a good Susan Mayer
for marina the Kiev subway evokes some
of the most vivid memories of her life
here as a young girl and some of her
happiest moments
they ask the call solutions the biggest
difference to the subway in Germany is
the smell it smells like earth like soil
like the Metro the trains are deep
underground
there's kilometers of earth above us and
the stations are works of art every one
of them it's the city's main form of
transportation but it's also a space of
culture and of art everybody who lives
in Kiev takes the metros whatever their
income whatever their destination that's
different here because in Germany there
are certain types of people you'll never
find on the subway and that will punish
defendants
in a few minutes the platform will be
full again at night the bright neon
advertising lens Ukraine's capital a
glitzier and poor effluent look but
marinas thoughts are elsewhere she's
going to pay a visit to some political
compatriots from ukraine's pirate party
their president Sergei Regan organized
the meeting here in the cellar of a Kiev
student bar they talk politics
that's the Ukrainian pirates they hadn't
founded an official party though because
they don't want to be corrupted
launching a political party costs a lot
of money in Ukraine if we transplanted
Germany's pirate party to Ukraine we'd
fail miserably because of all the
corruption in Germany the Pirates deal
with the issues of an affluent nation we
say we need greater transparency in the
political system but here they don't
even have a functioning political system
yet so the Pirates here are a cultural
force they try to create open
infrastructures and networks they
connect Ukrainian schools with European
schools so the children can learn
foreign languages over Skype and
exchange ideas and values with Europe
they want to teach children to be
responsible for their surroundings and
their society they understand if people
can't get organized if a building
Association can't even get a new garbage
can without calling the president then
they'll never have a democracy and see
what kind of democratic society is
overdue for a change the people know
what they want but they also need a
direction and we can play a role in
giving a direction
the Pirates are just a small group but
we can also play our part and organizing
people and in taking power away from the
state the powerful and mighty people up
there don't do anything nothing at all
we have to take power into our own hands
until they realize that they are the
powerless ones not us
night has fallen on the Maidan the art
of the Ukrainian protest movement and
the home away from home for some of the
protesters
The Sound of Music is coming from one of
the tents listen people I just found one
of my songs that I wrote back in 1999
and the lyrics matched the current
events perfectly it's about people who
are forced to defend themselves so it's
about us singer and his band are singing
about freedom and about people who are
determined to reach their goals and
about men who set aside thoughts of
their women as they look to the future
and to their struggle
the next morning marina pays a visit to
another place that reawakens childhood
memories a hospital in the center of the
city the Chernobyl nuclear disaster
shook Ukraine and the world in 1986
marina vice bunt was born a year and a
half later my mother told me that my
story is fairly typical of what happened
to children who were born near Chernobyl
and that's the only reason why I speak
about it publicly
I wasn't healthy as a child very
unhealthy I had problems at a very young
age but that was normal that happened to
many children including many of my
cousins I had one diagnosis after the
other and eventually the doctors say
what can you do
she's a Genova Scalia did you attend
noble baby and they said there was
nothing they could do that's when my
mother decided to leave for the West she
figured if anything could help it would
be Western medicine I forgot my besties
have it it's you not all of these
memories are easy for marina but what is
especially upsetting to her is the state
of health care in Ukraine today there's
no proper health insurance health care
goes to those who can afford it yeah
both fetus of yet to Chicago I was
inside many Soviet hospitals and spent a
lot of time there it's not pretty back
then and to some extent still today the
rules were that children couldn't have
visitors because the hygiene rules won't
allow it
but when it comes to hygiene they don't
see it as a problem that the rooms where
the medical instruments are being
disinfected are infested with mildew
they have a very crude understanding of
what hygiene is about Soviet hospitals
weren't very pleasant and Ukrainian
hospitals still aren't very pleasant
not all that much has changed in that
respect converse for myself in the
afternoon marina sets out to explore the
traces of Jewish Kiev despite her own
Jewish roots this chapter of her journey
is a voyage of discovery from marina
even after the Holocaust Kiev was home
to hundreds of thousands of Jews today
most have gone elsewhere to places like
Israel Germany in the u.s. marina has an
appointment with the rabbi have a
reformed synagogue today is Friday
Sabbath services will soon be underway
rabbi Alex de Courtney is pleased to
have a visitor from Germany he shows
marina his new and modern synagogue
building and says he wishes that Jews
like marina would return to their home
country I come from a very secular
family it took a long time for me to
realize that my family was Jewish I
didn't know it when we lived here in
Kiev this fan it didn't affect me for
most of my life when did I - kind of it
wasn't until I was in Germany that I
found my way back to it that's it was my
own wish not something from my
upbringing or tradition I didn't have
that at home
and then the Sabbath service begins a
small handful of people are here to
celebrate what remains of Jewish life in
today's Kiev want to see what I left
behind what might have been a chapter in
my life if things had been different
yeah it interests me it must be a
strange situation most Jews have left
Ukraine only very few still live here
that's meaning it's what could be
the members of this small Jewish
congregation in Kiev tell marina that
anti-semitism still exists in Ukraine
but it's gotten less in recent years
they say later that Friday evening the
weekend is approaching it was to be the
last peaceful weekend the city would
experience before the escalation on
February 18th
but like semantics in debt compared to
the Kiev of my childhood it's much more
international now you see faces on the
street that aren't just Ukrainian the
culture isn't just Soviet it's grown
more cosmopolitan and I really hope that
will continue after an eventful week
full of new impressions and old memories
it's finally time to relax
big jump band is performing at a club
called creative space
the fans are here in force
even years as if one I see people here
who are very open and cheerful they get
up spontaneously and start dancing
they're more open they're more willing
to forget the cares of the day today
Shana's and ukrainians have a special
talent for partying we have to dance and
listen to music at the barricades we
have to make jokes and paint paintings
how else could we survive all of this
on Tuesday February 18th the bloodiest
chapter in Ukraine's current protest
movement began
four days radical anti-government
demonstrators clashed on the streets
with the feared special riot police unit
the backwoods
scores of people were killed in the
violence morena vice fund had returned
to Germany less than a day before but in
her thoughts she's still back in Kiev on
livestream on the internet on television
and radio she follows the events minute
by minute and she's afraid for the
people she left behind
and momentous make me out in the moment
the question isn't how to create a
better democracy it's a question of
survival I hope things will improve
after an election but I'm not sure I
think it'll take years before we can
build a reasonable healthy democracy the
Maidan lies in ruins the future of the
country is more uncertain than ever my
fear is that the situation will escalate
to the point that radical elements will
win a new election that might even be
worse than yet a Kovach's government I
hope that won't happen I hope that
people will be too smart for that group
Anoka City neat hints are given it was
an eventful and emotional journey home I
was never as happy about visiting
Ukraine as I was this time and even if
I'm separated from the events now even
though it's all happening far away I'm
still there somehow I was there I
understand what they're thinking I saw
how they planned those defense systems
and what tactics they were practicing I
know those people and I looked into
their faces that might be the only
aspect that makes this bearable for me
at the moment I'm not a tourist in
Ukraine and right now I'm not a German
politician watching events on livestream
I'm also a part of this movement
someone's been o tired easily
you